hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the final round
of defeated candidates tournament it is
and we said that we will cover at least
one more game at uh show the the final
standings in the previous video that
we've shown uh the one one of the games
was still uh going on the alireza versus
Fabi game uh for those of you who don't
know uh Fabi lost that game and he had
uh well he had a really uh rough second
half of the tournament first half of the
tournament uh caruana played brilliantly
but in the second half uh he just fell
apart probably trying to catch up to
nipple who was just getting uh seemingly
effortless wins and it didn't work out
for him and then he just started losing
games uh but okay this is another game
it is a rapport versus her job off so
let's see what happened in this one and
also uh here's a nice photo of them
before the actual game there you have it
um I'm not sure who the gentleman making
the first move for apertise if any of
you know do share in the comments
section below and also one thing to now
notices that uh for some games report
comes uh in you know completely black
and white and on some games he comes in
a very very uh colorful Edition like
we've had in that one game uh where you
guys uh couldn't decide if that was a
red a red color rose color or or a
salmon color but yeah seemingly he does
perform better in mature cheerful uh
colors uh but okay getting back to the
game Rapport has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 now sorry about that
uh we have E5 by our job of uh Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 and the bishop to B5 he
goes for the not for the Italian Bishop
to B5 he goes for the real Lopez Knight
to F6 the Berlin defense again in this
tournament uh and now D3 uh because
we've had it's been kind of a theme of
the uh this candidates tournament uh
whoever lost a game playing the Berlin
defense uh so Bishop to C5 with Bishop
captures D captures and Knight B to D2
so nothing new here this is all been
played before Bishop to E6 uh and here
castles if any of you are still
wondering why not capture the the C5
Pawn we've shown it uh quite a few times
but Queen D4 and you can resign so
hopefully none of you were considering
this so here now we have castles uh in
the now of course uh that the king is a
safe the E5 Pawn can be captured so just
the bishop back to D6 you could also
play Queen to D6 but uh Java prepared
Bishop to D6 Knight the B3 and now the
position is a known one it's been before
between some very very strong Grand
Masters but interestingly it's also been
played in round one of this candidates
tournament between Fabiano Cortana and
Hikaru Nakamura Nakamura went Queen to
E7 and Fabi won that game very early on
in the tournament but here not Queen D7
here at Java plays C5 and it is now as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game which is which is complete
Madness you know in a Berlin defense for
a movie to have a completely new game uh
but okay uh here it's pretty standard
when you have doubled pawns you just
want to push one of them and trade it
off for your opponent's uh undoubled
Pawn so that way you get rid of a
doubled Pawn but also for the moment you
have complete control over that D4
Square so you don't have to worry about
any uh the D4 coming soon so Knight to
A5 here Robert wants to play B3 uh B3
and put the Knight on C4 so if black
ever decides to capture you can play B
captures on C4 still control the center
and have a nice semi-open B file for
your rook and here you can't go B6 if
you go B6 right away then Knight C6 says
uh well just game over on this level you
you attack the queen and also once the
queen moves you're gonna win that E5
Pawn so Queen to C8 guarding the B Pawn
and the Now Pawn to B3 like we said
preparing Knight to C4 Castles by the
job of end Bishop to B2 nicely feeling
ketoing the dark Square Bishop with
Bishop to G4 and now Knight the C4
putting pressure on this bishop uh Rook
to E8 and now we have Pawn to A4 so just
nicely expanding Bishop to H5 looks like
a a weird move but um rajabu wants to
play Knight to D7 he wants to move the F
Pawn and then put the bishop on F7 to
shift it over to this diagonal so Queen
to E2 we have Knight to D7 and now Queen
to E3 hoping to infiltrate with Queen to
G5 so Queen to d8 stopping this and now
King the H1 and now when you see a move
like King to H1 without the well sort of
uh even a long-term possibility of a a
queen or a dark Square Bishop getting to
this diagonal uh you know uh what's
coming Rook the G1 and the G4 is coming
so Rapport
does not have you know a peaceful game
in mind so here F6 strengthening the E5
Pawn also preparing special back then
uh to F7 and it now comes Rook to G1 and
uh you don't have to play it like this
you could also play Knight the H4 uh now
you control uh D squares nicely you can
play F4 next you want to try and open up
this diagonal for the dark Square Bishop
so there are many ways to play this and
this is perfectly fine for white but
that's just not a rapid style and that's
why we enjoy Robert's game so much Rook
to G1 preparing G4 Bishop back to F7 and
upward still goes G4 now he wants to
play G5 captures uh and open up the G
file for The Rook so here uh rajava
plays H6 which kinda stops G5 but it
also weakens the Light squares quite a
lot so again Knight the H4 is definitely
a move to consider but uh that's just
not a Robert style like tal he wants the
attack to happen as soon as possible and
he starts the attack right away with the
G5 and now what can you play here yeah
obviously you have to capture this Pawn
it's a free Pawn but what to capture it
with uh well age captures on G5 seems to
be the way to go but our job of place F
captures on G5 which is also perfectly
fine uh if a job if a wrapper continues
playing in his style but here H4 seems
to be the uh the way to attack to tackle
this this will again allow you to open
up the G file uh and you don't have to
sacrifice pieces you've already
sacrificed some pawns but again that's
just not a report style he plays Knight
captures on G5 H Captain G5 and Rook
captures on G5 uh putting now pressure
on that G7 pawn and you know that Rook 8
to G1 is coming and uh our job of
doesn't deem it necessary to remove the
knight from C4 it's a it's a potential
attacker and well wrapper just sacrifice
some material so yeah he says the bishop
will be useful here so here at Bishop
Queen to F6 uh Bishop of course will
come to f8 um
uh the the guard the spawn here uh but
maybe that's one of the reasons that you
could capture the Knight now simply not
to allow Knight captures uh Bishop
because this bishop really wants to come
to f8 uh but okay Rook 8 to G1 putting
pressure here and now Bishop back to f8
and now uh it's a really crazy position
uh you know depending on how long you
allow the engine to Crunch the numbers
uh you know uh you either get uh zero
zero zero zero zero or you get a
completely winning position for white or
for black depending on uh what move you
play but it's something that Anish giri
said uh perfectly during the uh coverage
of the final round he said that it
doesn't matter if the engine shows like
uh minus half or minus one or minus one
and a half or minus two or even minus
two and a half the position is either
lost or it's a draw it doesn't matter if
it's if it's lost then it's minus 100 or
minus one thousand and if it's a draw
then it's 0.00 doesn't matter what what
the engine is saying it can either be
one by force or it can so it's a you
know listening to the engine saying oh
it's a one and a half two and a half
it's uh it's either winning or it's not
so uh also something to consider maybe
when uh preparing for your games or
evaluating positions uh and here we have
Queen to H3 or no a queen to H3 is
definitely something that upwards spent
quite some time in calculating uh
because it's incredibly tricky you of
course you want to put more pressure on
that g file but just to show you quickly
what would happen Bishop to E6 we would
now of course win a Tempo and then grab
the Knight Queen G2 put pressure on the
G7 pawn bishop captures the B captures
and now rookie 7 add another Defender
here and you get this position uh where
it's not easy to find moves let's say
Rogue G6 attacks the queen queen to H4
and now Bishop to C1 uh going after that
queen or you could just repeat The Rook
G4 Queen uh Queen F6 and so on but if
you want to continue let's say Bishop C1
Rook the F7 now attacking the F2 on F3
and now Rook the E8 and finally after
Rook to H6 because that's why you put
the bishop and C1 to go after the queen
queen to E7 and now Queen H3 threatening
Checkmate but now Rook to F6 and now
you've um uh created this F7 Escape
Square for the king and the game of
course continues it's quite a quite a
while the game on of course if Queen H5
we just captured The Rook so it's not a
problem so that's one of the
possibilities it doesn't bring all that
much to White so Robert tries uh Rook to
F5 we have Queen to H4 by rajabov and
now Knight the D2 one would expect that
now that uh rapidly this Rook the five
that he would go after the E5 pawn and
it's also possible for example Knight
captures Knight captures we just trade
everything Bishop captures but now
rajabu would have This brilliant Rook
captures an E5 move that just eliminates
a very important attacker and after Rook
captures at Bishop to D6 and now the
Rook cannot move because of Checkmate
here and if you play Queen G5 offering a
queen trade threatening Checkmate hoping
for a queen characters and real
characters uh just Queen H7 again you
prevent The Rook from moving because of
Checkmate and now after F4 is played
this is all forced calipers captures you
get this position where black will
always be a little bit better black is
up a piece and even though okay those
pawns are looking a bit scary uh nothing
to worry about so a rapport does not
like his chances there he tries to go
the other way Knight to D2 now he wants
Knight F3 Knights the G5 and then
hopefully Checkmate the the black king
but now Rook E6 now the other Rook is
coming to help out with the defense and
also with the attack F4 finally trying
to open up this diagonal but it just
Rook the G6 now threatening Rook
captures on G1 Knight F3 attacking the
queen here and the queen to H3 by
rajabov you could also play the forcing
Rook captures on G1 we can show it
because it's very nice and now Queen to
age 6
asking why to what do you play here but
there really isn't all that much for
example if F captures an E5 Bishop G6
and The Rook now doesn't really have
good squares if you go Rook G5 then
Bishop H5 and that's it the Knight is
hanging once you defend it we just
capture it captures captures Rook 8
there's no point in continuing this
white is just down a piece that Knight
that was sacrificed without any serious
compensation so instead we have Queen to
H3 in the now F captures an E5 Rook
captures on G1 Queen characters and now
Bishop to H5 so a similar similar
attempt uh Knights the G5 finally the
Knight comes the square attacks the
queen here and you have to move the
queen and you have to move it well
otherwise it's not going to be a winning
position anymore however it's not all
that problematic to see what happens if
you play something like Queen H4 then E6
and now all of a sudden you have
problems the bishop Comes Alive the
Knight is hanging and for example
believe Knight F6 we can just capture
Knight captures G captures now Knight F3
check and the black loses the queen so
the queen is not very well placed on H4
so Queen to G4 was played offering a
queen trade and now not a lot of good
moves for Rapport uh he of course avoids
the queen trade and now Bishop to E7
putting pressure on the Knight here
Ponta E6 the bishop finally comes alive
but now Rook to f8 uh and what can you
play here obviously you might consider
capturing this Knight because it's a
free piece so why not but after Rook
captures an F5 and E captures an F5
Bishop captures and G5 attacking the
queen and you don't have to worry as the
E8 square is covered and also if you try
something like this maybe to pick up the
bishop and then bring another queen into
the game we will of course do no such
thing we're just gonna play King to H7
and now the position is winning uh
doesn't really matter what you do
because white is getting checkmated uh
you could bring another queen into the
game doesn't really matter just Queen 3
check and now it's uh you know just
check check just check and you get
checkmated Queen captures Queen captures
this comes with checking to G2 Bishop F3
checking G3 Bishop P2 check it's a very
well known checkmating pattern so of
course uh no uh no Mysteries here uh so
that's what you have what happens if you
go after after the night it's a very
tricky move but Knight to F7 was played
here and now rajab will just plays
special characters on F7 as it doesn't
really make all that much difference e
captures not an F7 but on D7 uh the
capturing that F7 is into all that
impressive either if you capture here
just real captors and again there's not
not nothing for white to look for Here
white is just down material so instead e
captures on D7 was played in the now
Bishop to E6 by Timur Andy was in this
position and move 33 that rehab Rapport
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here everything is
hanging there is nothing to you know
continue the game for if you go for this
with checking captures again not much to
look for one checking G8 and again you
can't continue you're down a full bishop
and uh that that's just it uh so yeah
really wonderful uh game by both uh
Rapport and rajab over Rapport always
goes for uh goes for the win he always
tries to play the the most beautiful
chest possible and you know in this
position for example after H6 uh not
going for the standard Knight H4 which
pretty much everyone would do just you
know winning the light squares pushing
F4 trying to open up the bishop he just
goes to G5 just you know full barbarian
uh approach uh I I love it but yeah
against very strong opponents it doesn't
work all the time but sometimes it works
and then you get a morphy head for your
for your efforts uh so yeah really
really nice reputation by the job of and
a very very clean execution in the end
only 33 moves so very good stuff and so
we don't forget now that all of the
games have finished these are the final
standings of the Fida candidates
tournament 20 22 so let's check it out
the winner is Yani pomishi who won the
tournament a full round a full round
ahead of the the end of the tournament
so he only needed 13 Rounds uh and he
won it with nine and a half points and
that's five wins nine draws and zero
losses incredible result the only player
undefeated in the tournament being lyron
in second place with eight points he did
lose two games but he won four so yeah
good for him with seven and a half we
have a tie between a job of and Hikaru
Nakamura with six and a half Fabiana
corvana uh who you can see got four
losses and all of those four losses were
in the second half of the tournament so
a tough break for Fabi he had a
brilliant start but then messed it up in
the end alireza again had a very slow
start in the first half but then he
started winning in the second half and
in the end he got sixth place and uh
sharing last place young shishov Duda in
the riharthroport with five and a half
points so there we have it those are
those are the final standings really
incredible stuff as you know
now has the right to challenge Magnus
constant for the title and if Magnus
will play that will be the match however
if Magnus decides not to play for
whatever reason I don't know if if I
mention this um Magnus did meet with
khadid work which you defeated president
during his stay in Madrid I believe two
days ago where some terms were probably
discussed uh I don't know if any
information or you know regarding this
conversation was made public not to my
knowledge it was not but I will keep you
guys informed so they did meet what they
discussed who knows but probably it had
something to do regarding the match so
if Magnus will not play then uh
yaniponishi will face the ingleren for
the title of video world champion now of
course everyone wants magnets to play
because it's not fair to Yan if you know
he just uh okay it wouldn't be fair to
Yan if he was just awarded the title uh
like you know carpal was when he was
playing against fisher fisher said he
will not plan and then karpov just
became world champion and then you had
to prove for years and years that you
are worthy and that people will you know
at least start taking you seriously of
course karpov achieved that but it took
quite some time uh but here okay even if
Magnus doesn't play and nepo has to play
against
um uh ding I mean if even if you beat
ding in a classical match you deserve to
be world champion because uh no one can
claim that they will be able to do that
uh you know
even once uh so yeah the future is
definitely exciting we'll see what it
brings
um uh but uh you know uh good stuff good
good stuff whatever happens uh so yeah
that's the game and this short coverage
of the tournament I hope you guys
enjoyed that and now we are going to
check out some of your suggestions that
I've seen you guys have been sending me
emails with the game suggestions and
such and also I'm planning on continuing
the sagas at the next Saga is the
Wilhelm steinit Saga of course it makes
sense as it comes after Paul Murphy so
we're gonna make one video I still have
to make the conclusion to The morphe
Saga because morphe just you know
abruptly stopped playing chess and then
you know he never played again uh you
know aside from some games where he gave
um odds of a move and a pawn uh but yeah
we're gonna discuss what happened with
morphe and why he stopped playing and
then we will start The steinit Saga uh
so yeah I once again really hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Gregory Thomas Gideon Franklin Jim Trent
studio manikandan and my Michael Colbert
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day